hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to for the days and the
escaping of the don't do no no hi guys
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dont escaped for
we've got spiders that are so excited to
eat my face off they're shooting cobwebs
out of their butt holes into the sky in
celebration of my future death but we're
not gonna give them the chance stupid
I'm not gonna give them the chance
so we're gonna go over into the
wasteland and now that we know what
we're gonna do now we can get through
this in so much better fashion I can
kind of like I can kind of get things
done quickly like I can make this work
you know what I mean I can make it work
i I know what I'm doing man I can't I
can't lift as much Vic this version of
myself isn't as lifti as the other one
was so we'll pompous and we'll Blum piss
alright so now I know it wants me to
drop this and in the wasteland
this is gonna be so cool cuz now like
there's gotta be a way to save everybody
and if I can save everybody then I can
have everyone there and there can be a
way to make sure that the the problem
was there was something that we couldn't
pick the desk I could have written it
down alright okay I don't remember
exactly what it was but there was
something it was like you couldn't pick
the destination of where you go so it
defaulted to emergency mode and then you
had to you had to basically be back in
your own body but with this we can
launch ourselves off into another body
where this ain't gonna happen and that
way we don't have to make mistakes well
this place looks promising oh yeah it do
oh yeah do I don't have a map yet so
let's just go for this we know what we
need to do here or at least generally I
know what I need to do here are a door
it's locked
y'see lau who knows i forget if the back
door is open yeah the water sprayer is
is the water sprayer ever used
i honestly have no idea he made a joke
about it at the end of the game but you
know i don't know there's a short pipe
here i'm kind of thing
there I should find a way to get into
that house before I start fiddling with
things and hey wait there's only one
Inlet things are gonna be slightly
different
Oh things are gonna be yeah
what bum ski all right get in there oh
yeah yeah crash it all out oh hell yeah
oh yeah photo old lady I don't know if
anything would be different or if it's
actually important than anything's
different at all we got to take that
definitely we got to fix it eventually
I'm not worried about it right now but
we will eventually fix it go upstairs we
just need to grab everything that's
available for now cuz I'm gonna kind of
like hyper speed through this with not
much in the way but these spiders are
gonna be the biggest problem it was a
paper clip holding suffer together the
documents don't use invoices wait I got
a paper clip I don't remember getting a
paper clip before uh things are slightly
pervert I love it I love it okay I can
put the documents away cuz I'm pretty
sure that's just gonna be like 410 in
the kindling tinder LinkedIn Durling me
if I need to make that happen okay so I
can probably pick a lock with that or
something of that nature
oh this is so cool it's locked I wonder
why and now I don't have to be paranoid
about locking and unlocking again
because that'd just be stupid okay so
now I'm gonna go east first I know the
gas station I know all that jazz what
about over here I remember this place I
remember it
yeah okay spiderwebs
okay you're telling me that no no no all
right so that's a bite mark that I
probably need to remember that's
probably important yeah let's inspect
the car cars busted and ignition coil
getting it out won't be easy adjustable
wrench well hey there you go oh the
small leaflet tucked in between the
ripped clothes I said this week we've
been hired by the locals to deal with
the outbreak some pride a mutated
spiders supposedly all the space
radiation us up there
I know it sounds strange but it's real
don't get to hope to get superpowers
with about you of the powder let
paralyzes the you live anyway we have
some scent repellents left in stock
James identified two assured species of
those creatures will be discouraged by
we saying he probably wrote it down to
somewhere just ask him alright
yeah it's ectoplasm it's covered in Shh
our ghost was in here oh I need a
crowbar oh wait
and try to pick the lock yes please
everything's different things are bear
traps for spiders more like spider traps
all right what do we got in there uh
hell yeah
B oh god what's with all the bees
alright whatever I guess I'm gonna have
a lot of bees I'm guessing I need a
specific type for the spiders yeah
probably it's locked how about the paper
clip uh yeah the Erebus oh yeah duct
tape let's put duct tape on the handle
nevermind I need a new handle I forgot
alright whatever you know I tried it's
all good alright nothing there and a
note here we go guys if you manage to
catch one of them make sure to check out
their teeth we have to make sure we use
the correct repellent or otherwise it
won't do anything okay so this one add
two big bites in for small bites I think
it's a b-36 what I'm gonna need I should
have waited until I actually saw that
before that but how would I have known
that it's not like I've been in the
future or anything to be let's see yeah
take it out I've removed the ignition
coil okay good that's all we're gonna
need let me double-check the bite just
in case too big and then four on the
outsides okay so we're gonna go to the
bridge first we're gonna grab this punk
we're gonna combine this with this with
the knowledge of forethought I and a
genius I think it'd be worth it to go
back home at this point and drop some
stuff off I need the nails that's right
I need the nails oh it's so smart
I'm so smart okay put the bear traps
away put the insect repellent away I
only need b-36 anyway which is right
here the rest over there useless useless
useless water sprayer very useful
obviously incredibly useful by the way
we're gonna be flying through this I've
got tons of time on the first day I have
all the time the
nails nail nail nails all right let's go
up in here let's put the ignition coil I
put it away now we got it now we're
going for now we're getting and now
we're going strong and hot and heavy ok
well the car could be started I guess
but it doesn't look very good obviously
a wheel is missing the ignition coil is
busted it has no fuel
all right well ignition coil bada-bing
bada-boom habu ski or Nevin saw this
part good great gotcha all right now we
can get out of here we need to get some
fuel in a wheel I can also ahead and
basically make one bridge for me too
that's a lot of time that's fine
yeah it'll save time on travel so let's
just go ahead and go Road West cuz
that's enough to get me across and then
I got three nails left to make the
barricade what the [ __ ] these goddamn
spiders what are they here already this
is disgusting what are they just like
hundreds of them walk in and just they
fart out all this everywhere what is the
point there's nothing to be gleaned war
[Music]
all right well um but um um okay
all right that's that's new I'm a wacky
with a wrench
it hasn't noticed me yet I'd rather keep
it that way I don't want to go near that
spider [ __ ] okay I guess yeah you know
what you right oh it's too heavy I have
to put something down first do I okay
I'll put down let's see the I don't like
that sound I don't like the change in
music I don't like that at all I'll put
down the the super sprayer who needs it
put you down that light enough now all
right let's put down the wrench cuz I
need it here anyway to get the gas so
let's just do that it's too heavy
where's 9 9 pounds you say well put this
short pipe down as well all right let's
take this cuz I want to get it all in
one go all right well a rock is that
what that rocks for you telling me rocks
for throwing at a Spidey I bet it is I
bet it is I gotta be careful though
because otherwise I'm gonna lose my
stuff okay metal bars metal bars metal
bars I can leave the nails here as well
because those are for the metal bars
okay so I think that's got to be it I
can't like distract the spider with the
small rock it all makes sense it all
makes sense okay we're gonna well let me
get my stuff first before I do any of
that [ __ ] let me get this let me get the
plastic wrap too just in case
did you never know I don't think that
was too heavy now it wasn't let's throw
the rock over here I don't want to get
oh come on stop being such a [ __ ] for
the rock at the spider okay there's got
to be a way to distract it it's got to
be something to do with throwing the
rock no come on that mix
[Applause]
alright I'm gonna [ __ ] shoot you okay
we're good we're all good grab the cash
grab the cash think it's tan there's a
lighter charcoal I don't think I can
carry that newspaper stand loser
explosion we all know about that should
I shoot this guy gonna shoot you all
[ __ ] all right well I'm down a bullet
but you know that I think all worth it
corpse this man is dead covered by webs
and parsley
I don't want to touch him well you think
that spiders better than you you let
that spider touch that man but not you
you stupid fool
thank you rock you really did a good you
really you really did a good you did a
great actually
you did a great let's get some gas up in
this ass ah wrench I know what to do now
I know all of what to do I know so much
of what to do oh yeah it's too oh [ __ ]
that's fine I guess I could drop the rap
for now I don't think I need them I
don't think any way I could drop the
rock too and I think that it's I think
it's just fine I don't need those to
survive tonight I think if anything
needs metal bars its giant spiders
they're gonna definitely need the metal
bars so I can leave those there
let me save just in case okay so we're
gonna go back I need to put the metal
bars on the window that's number one
let's go ahead and put this on the
window here cuz I know we're gonna do
this yeah yeah yeah put this one right
there yeah yeah now I'm using my time
more efficiently oh I don't have the
other one yet yeah oh man I'm flying
with this I'm and now I know you got to
put the bear traps on the outside that's
what's important about that all right
all the windows have been barred and now
I'm gonna bring this out and this out
because they need to go to the backyard
to the barn here I need to eventually
fix this [ __ ] cookie cookie co put the
duck a tip on a dot put the it's
definitely be 36 yep be 36 okay
one needs their emergency power we're
going to the water pump we're gonna
start it oh yeah
oh that's right I need fuel for this
well good thing I didn't put it in the
truck already because I'm not gonna get
the truck started now there we go okay
so the water pumps ready oh and I know
how to do this now let's do over oh nice
spray mist blanket spoink a spoink a
spoink cos now I know the secret to it
okay efficiencies a maximum that's all
good to go
found an abandoned house hunting rifles
and bullets not a perfect weapon
probably will help but until the iron
bars schedule the water Springs for the
wall miss will this be enough no of
course not you idiot I might still have
time to go get some gas right now I
think I still have time I think I do
yeah I I do I do I definitely do okay
let's go get some gas because there is
time because I built that road like a
smarty and I can get these things you
never know when you're gonna need
plastic and Rock and about a boo ski
saving time for later cuz now I don't
have to gas it up now I just bring back
the wheel that's gonna save me on
another day my efficiency is gonna pay
off in dividends or that in their fuel
the car the wheels still missing but
that's all set and ready to go this is
ready to go let's go ahead and close the
door here and then lock it and let's go
ahead oh wait I bear traps that's right
so we need to put bear traps no no no no
no no no you silly [ __ ]
bear trap bear trap put one in front and
one in back sound good to me yes yes so
let's go in here and let's close the
door
let's lock her up and I think that's all
she wrote for this
I think if I've done my math correctly
there's nothing else I need to do can I
improve my chances somehow I don't think
so I put the poison out for the right
spider there's no repellent device I've
got everything I need
yeah no work we're good to go yeah let's
do this
alright let's go for it and hunting
rifle or the evening sky darkened is a
pack of huge spiders followed you send
you found a hiding place in an abandoned
farmhouse an automated sprinkler system
kicked in as the pack was getting near
despite being old and faulty the
sprinklers worked perfectly fully
covering the air above the fields where
the dense mist spiders were not afraid
of water at all
however there was a strong repelling
mixed with the water it scared off six
spiders you decided to set up some traps
outside the house he placed two traps
outside your hideout who have the
spiders walked right into them the front
door was closed
keeping away all the spiders that would
have ended through it the back door was
closed
keeping away all the spiders that would
have entered through it the window on
the ground floor was reinforced with
metal bars bars were nailed to the frame
out of four spiders that tried to enter
the house through that window
for stopped the window on the upper
floor was reinforced with metal bars for
spiders were stopped for spiders were
stopped yeah baby that's all them you
fan it off all the spiders before they
even entered the house you went to bed
early and had a well-deserved rest
allowing you to regain some strength oh
[ __ ] wait I forgot about that
could you not crash in my [ __ ] well
there we go again I wonder what the
night's gonna be all about dudududu it's
locked which is the window oh ah cold
that's what all the blankets were for
that is a cold that's cold hey wait a
minute oh that's not good what was that
the Attic oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I better check
it out was this an extension cured hatch
all right let me go see what's going on
aver hey lady hold it right there whoa
easy nice landing considering the fact
that it was flying on fumes and half of
the controls were broken I say I did a
good job
well then glad you're okay sorry for
your helicopter it wasn't really mind
blah blah blah now really mine hey lower
that gun I mean no harm you look
harmless alright thanks my name is Mark
okay okay okay maybe we're on the same
Oh they recognize you too than me we
were on the same train or bus one time
back in the old days or something like
that it was something else anyway do you
think you'd help me with something
how could I say no to a pretty lady with
a loaded gun in her hand I'm trying to
get somewhere an outpost what kind of
outpost spaceship I saw this gun oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah I'm just seeing if
there's anything new yeah that's the
same that's the same that's the same
I cool that's all I think it was mostly
the same as what it was before I'm gonna
take the screwdriver the nothing needs
there if it's gonna be cold we're gonna
need the chimney so I think we can clear
the bird that was out there okay it's
gonna be a slow walk huh oh wait I don't
have a I don't have a sticker and maybe
I do this short pipe would work I don't
think I have the the thing I need to
make it unstuck clogged by something I
can't reach it
okay I don't think I have what I need to
unclog it yet let's go ahead and while
you're here let's just undo the damage I
did with the windows yeah I suppose I
could have done it with someone else
here but whatever I'm gonna need some
nails that's why I'm gonna need the
nails to build the the truck replacement
thing nails go bye-bye
also go bye-bye water sprayer ash go
bye-bye I need one more pair of nails
ba-bye oh boy
guys guess who I am Who am I well I say
in the comments boy you'll never figure
it out you'll never know don't try you
can't do that yeah whatever is in the
mystery I'm an enigma yeah no one knows
who I am I don't even know who I am
okay anyway alright let's see where
we're going
alright this trap has caught something
disgusting I need some sort of tool to
reset its spring of a Kroeber oh well I
don't need it I don't need it now yeah I
don't think there's anything else I can
do here so let's go ahead and get round
outside see we've got two new locations
there let's see if there's any changes
here there might be that yeah the road
oh the bodies are gone - jeez tire
tracks the road is blocked maybe someone
went around let's see what's going on
yeah that's right this is worth we found
the RV ok looks like that trap didn't
end well oh god wonder what happened my
guess is the car broke down RVs are not
the best for off-road travel you know
they set up camp and then the spiders
got him well that's a shame he doesn't
have anything interesting not much for
that poor guy he's dead no valuable
belongings it's a 7 feet deep I just
really don't want to just jump in there
fair enough oh yeah the hook that's
right the hook it's hats with big bolts
well I got something to take off big
bolts
dude sets the hook alright there we go
bottles of water nothing we need those
first aid kit and is in there thermal
blanket that's always good
okay let's check in the closet all right
we got coats yeah that's we're gonna
need we're gonna need all the warmth we
can get we're gonna need a lot of warmth
backpack is full um we don't need the
water I know we don't need the water the
water is for heat not that we don't ever
need water but we don't need water right
now so I can always come back for that
if I need it later but right now I don't
think I'm unneeded let's go ahead and
make the other flank a hundred minutes
yeah that's fine we can do it it's all
good it's all good baby all good
actually I should have stopped by the
house drop off some of the [ __ ] my
backpack is full and a waste of time but
whatever all right let's go to the gas
station see what's new there I need to
get guests anyway because no matter what
we're gonna need to fuel up the
generator in order to power any sort of
heater that we're gonna have so we're
definitely gonna need that and then when
we find the wheel we're gonna get the
vehicle and all it's gonna be good there
let's see if anything is different in
here I don't think so
I think so Oh to charcoal we are gonna
need that okay that's cool but that was
heavy wasn't it ah [ __ ] it was heavy
okay this is a little inefficient but
we're gonna need to do this eventually
so I'm just gonna go back again I'm
gonna drop the stuff off because we're
gonna need it and yadda yadda yadda all
right so now let's go to the restaurant
we can find the kid you know what's fun
we can actually just not even talk to
the kid and know how to know how to get
around I should uh I should check the
front door first I'll screw that go away
come on I always fight you all right
whatever my name is David this is Kate
how do you know my name
I don't know it just came to me I know
you Cody I know stay away I don't know
you I think go away or else blah blah
blah okay all right blah blah blah I
know you Cody I know you okay so I got
to get around this I'm gonna go here
okay put the pipe in the rope there we
go
okay got this and the rope I think I put
the I think I left them no I didn't ah
yeah yeah that's what I'm talking about
that is what I am talking about there we
go in an Badu ski empty gas heater
that's good can of meat cupboard
cupboard cupboard it's locked well not
for long
Locke is too tiny I need to brute-force
this one that's fine Oh
knife freezer no food your own weird
shaped objects these are uh heat
absorbers I don't know if I need those
how much was that ten kilograms yeah I
don't think I need those so I'm pretty
sure I can just drop them here they are
a bit of a waste of space and I can
always come back and get them if need be
let's just drop them for now hi how'd
you get in there I'm David's twin it
does play here
it really does play that's funny
well I'm gonna be honest I use the back
door well I didn't know there was back
door
well more like a back window wow you're
like a burglar come on it's all
abandoned anyway wait why am I even
explaining myself to you did you find
any food in there take this food but how
do I open this
hand it back all open for you somehow
okay yeah let's just open it with the
screwdriver was that ten minutes versus
five minutes yeah yeah if I bet is good
kenta me for you
your takis what is that food wow you are
a good person after all wouldn't say
good maybe a bit clumsy and soft
come with us Cody you'll be safer we
might even have more food awesome
eh they're good how old are you
blablablabla we've already talked about
this a bajillion times that's fine okay
we got to go okay so we got everything
we needed there we get the flag for more
warmth yell it's under the ruined house
now oh it's sad man everything about
Barry is just so goddamn sad oh poor
Barry but I'm gonna keep you alive this
time hey please be there leave me alone
I mean you no harm
he's pretty much harmless okay please my
name is Mark Mon David let's go wait
Barry what do you want have we met
before
I don't wait ah did I meet you at the
gas station before the world ended or
something what's going on Kate
why do I keep feeling like I've been
here before Dreamz maybe no I mean yeah
but there's more to it than that well
whoever you are what do you want they're
not say the temperature at night is
gonna get crazy come with us we can help
each other sorry I see no reason to keep
going hi so we know all about this I
don't think that there's gonna be
anything else
okay I'm gonna she's gotta distract him
so she's gonna distract keep him busy
- gun ok there's gas but I don't think I
have the space for that right now I'll
come back for later ok electric heater
Oh cold bedsheet and a book small locket
around her neck what about the locket hi
Barry I'm sorry if you're reading this
Epperly means I didn't make it I know
you'll make the right decision alright
time for him to get a little angry
where'd you get it babbit of angry angry
angry angry angry angry angry angry
angry
listen there's a lotta loud noises
happening oh it said looks like the snow
is picking up - all right time for
shoveling it's still sad even though
it's already happened like it's still
sad and poor Barry thank you she
deserved that at least of course you did
we've got a plan sort of first part of
this plan is to survive tonight I'll do
it fern hey mister
yeah I'm Cody hello Cody I'm Barry do
you want some food from a can I left
some for later but I can share a sweet
of you but I'm not hungry right now
eating makes me happy and I thought it
would also make you happy hey is he your
son David now we found him by a
restaurant near here I'll tell you all
the details later go - you're a good kid
I think I'll eat that food now go for it
come on David lead the way alright but
we got to move okay how much does a
propane tank weigh first I have to
detach the hose disconnect the hose it's
too heavy okay I only got 6.5 left so I
can come back for it at some point I get
a wheel I'm not sure where but I know I
get a wheel somewhere okay but there's
plenty of time to go back and forth
because I think I got everything that I
need for right immediately now your
house is so cool it's not my home I
found it deserted so cool so there's a
place you stayed at and baby - baby -
baby - baby okay alright let's put some
stuff away because we got to go right
back to it so we do have blankets for
everybody
I mean whoever has to sleep in a flag
probably isn't gonna be too happy but we
do have all those so now that we have
that we can go back get the gas for the
propane for the heater there I don't
know where we're gonna find a wheel
Thank You forgeting about that wheel is
somewhere but back to the house go here
there was nothing else in the house that
we needed right I don't think that we
nabbed everything we stole everything
from you Barry hope you don't mind there
was nothing left at the restaurant that
I would need except maybe
let me go left here for real quick oh
not this again I hope there aren't any
spires left here I've seen their corpses
around the hideout and I wouldn't want
to meet them face to face to be honest
maybe it's just leftover webs leftover
or not they're blocking our way now you
think we can do something to get rid of
them it looked kind of strong enough to
trap an adult man in place I think we
should come back tomorrow hey we can
dissolve it somehow my guess is this
spaghetti of webs will dissolve on its
own by tomorrow let's just keep this
place in mind and come back later all
right whatever you say so just in case
because I hate leaving anything to
chance I'm gonna bring these tiles I
don't think that they're gonna be like
useful in any way I don't think the
waters gonna be useful but you never
know so I guess all right whatever I
think we've got everything that we're
gonna need guess out bring it here put
this in here we get to the house start
it up there we go back inside
let's close the back door let's lock her
up I don't know if that's gonna do
anything but at least we'll have that oh
let's go ahead and clear the bird if
it's a dead bird it might not actually
be a dead bird now I don't know what
it'll be yep dead bird
okay dead bird hey food hey Cody Cody
guess who's got some food for you okay
so in here there's some oh [ __ ] why did
I lock that already there's wood out
here broken planks they might be good
for burning I don't know if they're good
for anything structural wise they would
be good for burning like we've got
kindling baskets we might as well just
put the I play something at the fire to
actually fuel okay Brooke the planks do
I need to put any more all right so
we're gonna have plenty of kindling
okay and then put the planks in the
kindling basket let's put everything
that we've got all the paper the money
the documents all in the kindling basket
I'll need something like this kindling
to start ah what a wad of cash
there's already some kindling everything
that would prolong the fire is useful
but instead of burning it all once I
should put yeah literally anything that
can burn okay let's bring out the maybe
the dead bird can burn too for all I
know
create a smell but maybe that wouldn't
work you don't know that all right blue
coat
- Katherine give the green coat to Cody
so it's too big for me I know but you'll
have to wear it later when it gets
really cold Oh
okay you're good with kids David I don't
know am i yeah I'm not a kid
hey kids being really nice this time
around yeah that's peculiar I don't know
about that one our red coat to me
this brown cup to Barry the ovens on and
already going electricity electrical
heater extension cord okay cool let's
try putting a blanket over the window
okay so that's interesting
all right cool maybe I shouldn't have
used that nail on the plank cuz I'm
gonna need to nail up the windows okay I
think that was a mistake okay
let's let's correct that mistake then
let's go out let's get the nails back oh
I forgot my goddamn hammer uh okay three
hours left that's not a lot of time
we're cutting it close here a hammer I
thought I would have been more efficient
with this but apparently not wait oh no
oh no wait can I not oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
okay that's not good oh [ __ ] okay [ __ ]
Wow alright so that's that's bad great
oops
let's prioritize a few things can I put
thermal blanket on the passage now let's
put the thermal blanket on the lower
window I feel like that's gonna be the
most important thing to do and that's go
ahead and hammer it up okay so the
thermal blanket is there that's good um
let's go ahead and close this up and
let's lock her up the only problem is
one of these is wide open but this is
the bigger of the two
so I'm guessing that's moderately more
important let's go ahead and close the
ceiling hatch up here there's a big hole
in the wall here but I don't know what's
gonna do about that alright whatever
let's just go down I guess we'll just
stay down here let's go ahead and put
the electrical heater in I should open
it okay alright screwdriver to the
electrical heater oh my god ninety
minutes okay yeah alright oh it's very
close now thirty minutes left
[ __ ] I've never cut it this close ever
let's put this down gas heater I guess
you know it's not gonna be nailed up but
you know it's it's gonna be up at least
yeah there's nothing I could do alright
charcoal that's the last thing I can
think of a bag of charcoal in the
kindling box okay so that's about as
good as it's gonna get I wish I hadn't
nailed the other thing to the like built
that yet but you know that was me trying
to plan for something that I didn't need
to do
let's dude Oh empty bag might as well
put the empty bag there yeah about the
restaurant flag that wouldn't work ah
you don't know that you don't know that
come on live a little
alright let's see what happens I'm ready
wear a warm jacket oh it was cold
already during the day but when the Sun
disappeared behind the horizon the
temperatures dropped even lower it got
so cold that everything in the area was
alive and hadn't found a shelter was
president immediately you found shelter
in a house hoping it would save you from
the wave of cold death the front door
was closed this week in the wave by two
percent of the initial freezing power
freezing power back door was closed
two percent I think it's gonna be a lot
of little things ground floor was
covered similar silver thermal blanket
to thermal blanket was nailed four
percent was blocked four percent was
blocked covered hang in there swept away
by the windows rule three percent that's
still something you didn't put anything
on there in the all [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
oh I didn't like I didn't like that oh
[ __ ] oh no oh [ __ ] oh god oh god too bad
you were you were staying in the other
room making it less effective as well at
the oven raise the temperature but a bit
dispersing about 7% of the F Wow
oops warm coat coat nice and warm but he
didn't help the code was too severe his
body too fragile and you promised him
safety you were an old code whose thick
and warm through 10% oh god I really
didn't like oh my god look at the
[ __ ] face I'm so dumb and that's
right okay cool yeah wow you're right
you right oh wow that's funny that's
funny that's funny that's funny I did
not light the fire I'm so stupid
okay let's try that now front door 2% 2%
4% 4% had 3% with large hole the hatch
was an important air flow it stopped six
percent right maybe I should have put
the thermal blanket up there 30 percent
during the night a sudden strong gust
would almost put the fire
but you at a loss for kindling you
didn't lose any heat full fuel to burn
and kept the fire going till dawn or all
its 7% of the freezing power you plugged
in electrical heater in the main room 23
percent and 24 percent have we done yes
okay there you go it wasn't as bad as
you thought it would be conditions
outside I didn't like the freaking fire
I'm so stupid
everything in your hideout was
absolutely fine to even get it got a bit
chilly but you didn't even need to put
the coat on you were able to rest much
more comfortable in any thought you
would yes yes I did what's gonna wat the
[ __ ] stairs this is new
what the [ __ ] whoa what the [ __ ] hi Oh
what the [ __ ]
hello Maggie how are you hello dear what
wait your must be dreaming indeed you
are my dear I know you I buried you
you're Barry's wife yes you did bury me
honey I'm quite grateful for that no
problem it's a dream yes darling it's
quite obvious once you look around and
think for a second you've been here
before but your memories failing you
it's from dream travelling you've got a
watch out as you do it it can lead to
dementia I don't understand I hope you
will because a lot of it depends on it
Barry is your husband yes darling there
for some reason you're in my dream well
not personally I'm dead remember I'm
just an echo of Barry's memory of me why
are you here I'm here because you let
Barry die honey what no that's
impossible he's fine oh maybe now he's
fine but he didn't survive your previous
life previous life you've been here
before
deep inside you know it's true what's
gonna happen can you tell me you care
for your friends darling you're a good
man and I don't want that boy to get
hurt either but if you try you could
save my husband too just don't let him
go there go where the sand tomb don't
let him go there tell him to wait oh
dear I think oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ]
I think our time has run out they've
found you who what is that run David
don't let this thing touch you um and
please warn Barry also tell him I love
him and that it wasn't his fault
uh-oh what's gonna happen hi you want to
fight you will fight buddy
you will fight or I'll fight you often
often often Hey Wow oh [ __ ] okay well
there I go whoops oh hi again oh god I
got to go through all this again
oopsies [ __ ] okay I'll be right back I
was too curious
- god damn curious ye okay oh [ __ ] oh
jeez oh jeez okay well that's it so you
had another bad dream yeah not a very
pleasant one there was a storm a
thunderstorm the rain was burning like
it was acid I think he was striking all
around I see then we'll have to prepare
for it what is it Cody you seem excited
I have something super important to tell
you like super duper important we have
to prepare for tonight even more than
yesterday
yes Cody I know you don't know why yet I
don't I thought I had a dream
there were like dozens of zombies coming
towards the house they wanted my brain
we have to protect it I don't want to be
eaten those ugly faces then we're slowly
walking with their arms in front of him
they were speaking to be all like brains
Cody zombies aren't real you had a bad
dream that's all what no what your
dreams are better than mine I'm not
saying they're better so you believe me
that there is Ami's coming after me no
one's chasing you Cody zombies will
think you're tasty David there's
something I have to tell you I also had
a dream you saw what I saw
no I saw a city I know where to find the
spaceship David or at least I know how
to look for it
what where sidereal the corporation that
built those ships had a number of
outposts and offices across the that
mean well everywhere in my dream I saw
one of them in a deserted city in the
southwest it was a dream of an office
but if we get there we might find the
location of the spaceship outpost so you
don't know how for certain even if I
doubted your dreams for one second I
need you to trust me on this one you've
got to get there as soon as possible
before we spend any time preparing for
what's coming tonight okay cool yeah
okay all right cool all right sure yeah
yeah
let's do it let me take these off and
let's go ahead and take this off
actually
oh no the robber would be better for
that the rubber might be better for that
yeah the rubber might be better okay
anyway so that's all the time I have for
this episode but let's finish this up in
one more episode this is great and just
because I know the general flow of it
doesn't mean that I am NOT ecstatic and
surprises around every corner this is
cool stuff script welder you outdid
yourself so thank you everybody so much
for watching expect another episode of
out about this very soon and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]